Back in 2010, when director Lee Unkrich first
pitched his idea to make Coco, it was going
to be a completely different movie than the
one we know and love today.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to reveal some
of the dramatic changes that Pixar made to
its nineteenth feature film during the course
of its development.
By the way, I'm running a giveaway for this
gorgeous Art of Coco hardback book filled
with stunning concept art for all my subscribers.
To enter, leave a comment below with your
thoughts about the Coco movie we never got
to see and make sure you're subscribed to
my channel.
Quick warning: I will be talking spoilers
for the movie, so take care if you've not
seen it yet.
Originally, Coco was going to be a full-on,
traditional musical, which would have been
a first for Pixar.
Yes, the film was going to feature six full-length
songs, including several show-stopping song-and-dance
numbers, all written by Robert Lopez and Kristen
Anderson-Lopez, the husband-and-wife song-writing
team behind Disney's Frozen.
Coco's creators even toyed with the idea of
naming the film "Remember Me" after Ernesto
de la Cruz's biggest hit, which was the first
song composed.
Indeed, speaking on the Q&A podcast with Jeff
Goldsmith, Coco's screenwriters revealed that,
in early versions of the movie, Miguel's ancestors
in the Land of the Dead were all cursed so
they couldn't talk, but could only communicate
by singing, which they all hated because,
as we know only too well from the final film,
the Rivera family absolutely hates music!
The filmmakers worked on this full-on musical
version of Coco for several years before eventually
abandoning that idea as they felt it just
wasn't working.
That's when they took inspiration from films
such as "Once" and "O Brother, Where Art Thou?"
and, instead of having the characters in Coco
burst into song about their feelings, they
decided to only include music that was driven
by actual performances, for example, when
Miguel sings on stage in the Land of the Dead
or when Héctor sings to Chicharrón, which
was a scene that co-writer and co-director
Adrian Molina came up with.
For the team behind Coco, this new approach
felt truer to the kind of tale they wanted
to tell and it also meant they could showcase
more Mexican-influenced music and make more
use of the extensive research they'd carried
out for the film.
On top of that, it also gave the filmmakers
more time to concentrate on the emotional
side of the story they were telling.
However, just because Coco changed from being
a full-on musical, doesn't mean that everything
the filmmakers worked on in that initial version
was thrown out.
For example, the papel picado sequence which
opens the final film actually started life
as part of a musical number in the middle
of the movie.
Speaking of Coco's opening scenes, that part
of the film changed several times over the
course of the film's development.
Initially, the movie was going to begin with
a full-on musical number called 'Día de los
Muertos', featuring performers on stage in
1950s Mexico City.
The filmmakers thought the song-and-dance
routine would help introduce the idea of the
Day of the Dead, especially to viewers who
hadn't grown up with that particular tradition.
So, the deleted opening scene includes important
items for the holiday, for example, the ofrenda,
an altar set up to honour a person's ancestors;
foods such as calaveras or sugar skulls, pan
de muerto or sweet rolls, and mole sauce;
and also marigolds, which you can see throughout
the performance.
This deleted scene was actually the first
scene that Adrian Molina story-boarded on
the movie.
And there's much to enjoy about it, including
the catchy tune which emphasises the celebratory
nature of the Day of the Dead, and there's
lots of clever little touches too like the
marigold design of the parasols carried by
the female dancers, and the way the altar
transforms into a skull and finally a full
skeleton.
"Día de los Muertos!
Día de los Muertos!
Día de los Muertos!"
[Music]
"The party just goes on and on.
On and on and on and on!
On and on!"
"On!"
"Día!"
"De los!"
"Muertos!
Muertos!
Muertos!"
"Ya!"
In the end, the filmmakers decided to cut
the musical opening as, instead, they wanted
us to meet the movie's main character Miguel
straight away so we could learn all about
him and his family and their polar opposite
feelings about music.
And lots more songs ended up getting the chop
after the directors decided against making
a Disney-style musical.
One of those songs was from the film's first
act and was called 'Way of the Riveras'.
Basically, Miguel's family sings to him about
what it means to be a member of the Rivera
family and how he must continue their traditions,
like it or not; which essentially means that
he has to make shoes rather than music.
And to emphasise that point, at the end of
the song, Miguel's grandmother swipes his
guitar away from him.
Now, I'm not a huge fan of this particular
song, but it gets across the idea of family
obligation that it was going for.
However, it does seem rather odd to have the
Riveras break into song to express themselves
when a major plot point of the movie is that
the Rivera family absolutely hates music!
And that's exactly what the creators of Coco
realised wasn't working about the full-on
musical version of the film.
"Rivera!
Rivera!
Rivera!"
"We do what we do because it is the good to
the beautiful life that we got!"
"Rivera!
Rivera!
Rivera!"
"Delicioso!"
"Riveras are thethered forever and ever and
ever and ever and whether we like it or not!"
"Thank you abuelita!
That was very educational."
"Now can I borrow your workbench?"
While the 'Way of the Riveras' tune didn't
make it into the final film, the movie does
include a scene that gets the same point across
by showing Miguel's relatives telling him
that from now on, after his school day has
finished, he'll join them working in their
family shoemaking business, because as they
tell him: 'You are a Rivera.
And a Rivera is a shoemaker.
Through and Through.'
However, the music wasn't the only major change
that Coco underwent during its six years of
production.
Director Lee Unkrich's original idea for Coco
was to tell the tale of a young boy in the
United States whose father was American and
whose mother was Mexican.
In the script for that initial story, the
boy visits Mexico for the Day of the Dead
and, as he faces his grief for his mother
who's passed away, he eventually learns to
move on and let go of her.
Of course, approaching the story in this way
would have meant that Coco would have been
told from an entirely different perspective,
specifically an American one.
What really changed the filmmakers' minds
was that, after several research trips to
Mexico and everything they discovered about
Día de Muertos, they realised that the story
they were planning to tell about grief and
'letting go of a loved one who's died' was
not what the Day of the Dead was actually
about.
Instead, Unkrich said he learned that Día
de Muertos, 'isn't about grieving; it's a
celebration.
It's about remembering those family members
and loved ones who've passed, and keeping
them close.'
So, the team behind Coco decided to ditch
their initial story idea, and focus instead
on the themes of family and music, setting
the movie entirely in Mexico.
Now, would you have liked to see Coco as a
full-on musical movie?
And what did you enjoy most about the final
film?
Let me know in the comments and also make
sure you subscribe for a chance to win this
beautiful Art of Coco book.
If you enjoyed this, remember to like and
share, and hit the notification bell to get
all my new videos.
And you can also tap the screen here to check
out all the easter eggs you missed in Coco,
plus some other cool Pixar videos.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!